a major media outlet is facing enormous
backlash after deleting a series of
horrifying tweets which seemed to
normalize pedophilia yes pedophilia usa
today
straight as you can get promoting an
article originally titled what the
public keeps getting wrong about
pedophilia arguing that the attraction
to minors is quote misunderstood here's
one of the tweets quote when most of the
public thinks of pedophilia they assume
it's synonymous with child sex abuse a
pedophile is an adult who is sexually
attracted to children but not all
pedophiles act out abuse kids and some
people who sexually abuse kids are not
pedophiles
after all kinds of outrage and
widespread disgust usa today today
decided to pull the entire tweet thread
saying that the tweet lacked context
because the full article was unavailable
because it was hiding behind a paywall
so
greg i hear you uh pedophile was the
thing in ancient greece
should we be kinder to misunderstood
pedophiles
no
how's that for an answer
what is it with the media and pedophilia
it's usa today usa today america's hot
you know
america's morning menu is now like a
house organ for perverts you got cnn is
employing them usa today defends them
you know i understand trying to get the
youth demo but this is a little
disgusting
by the way judge jeanine made a great
point on my show last night about this
this is all based on a lie that
pedophiles seek understanding and
treatment they don't they're perfectly
happy exploiting your desire to help and
there are no rush to reverse their
deviant instincts it's the opposite they
actually go to great lengths to plan and
to seed their perversions they put a lot
of work into it just read about that cnn
producer i mean he like flew people in i
mean it was i mean you had to do some
serious planning to to like you know
sexually trafficked teenage girls
uh dana is is this about that is this
about pedophiles or is this about the
dangers of reckless tweeting
well also just like where's the editor
right
who thinks that in this time of covid
apparently our democracy hangs in the
balance
inflation
crime that the most compelling issue for
a limited space in a national newspaper
is to run an op-ed
about defending pedophiles
honestly so and then there's twitter
which is stupid and they probably should
not have their social media team doing
twitter about that but also when you're
about to tweet something about defending
pedophiles think twice like it's okay
not to tweet
it's okay
when you're trying to
make a point and you want to put an
opinion editorial out there
usa today is like kind of the easy place
to get it it's harder to get it into the
new york times the wall street journal
the washington post but the most
effective place you can put it is
someplace like foxnews.com with the kind
of traffic we get oh
but we're not going to run your
pedophile
article but don't even try it
i'm glad you're glad you added that uh
now uh assuming it's true that not all
pedophiles jesse are child sex abusers
uh is this an attempt to normalize
dangerous behavior what do you think uh
oh yeah under the table but geraldo if
you are physically attracted to
something sexually
eventually you will do something
in terms of action
to to act on those urges
right
am i wrong geraldo
whether it's watching pornography child
pornography which is a crime
which is loitering i think you're
probably right right eventually in your
life you will act on that right if
you're lusting after a little child you
there's some there's really a screw loop
it's only a matter of something yeah
only a matter of okay a judge do you
feel that pedophiles deserve sympathy or
is this a
perilous is this dangerous what do you
think what do you think all right let me
tell you this
a right-wing pundit i am a person who's
been in the trenches going after these
pedophiles animals as i call them who
want to have sex with your children they
are devious they are cunning they know
who to target they know what kind of kid
to target maybe from a poor area where
there's no father figure and then they
target them they buy them things they
groom them they get their their get
their allegiance their friendship then
they molest them and then what they tell
them is no one will believe them i have
convicted people who the heads of
corporations and teachers and priests
and garbage collectors as well as uh
all kinds of doctors lawyers it doesn't
matter
you can till the cows come home tell me
the pedophiles don't act out you're
wrong they act out every time we we
catch them i've gotten them to go out
and look for a child the night before
they were going to be sentenced they are
animals they destroy the lives of their
victims and this is all an attempt to
normalize pedophilia and it's a sick
place that we are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else